the Starks reigned as kings for
thousands of years even withstanding the
invasion of the
Andals as the southern kingdoms fell and
the children of the forest were driven
away the north stood strong maintaining
its religious customs and its way of
life eventually the reign of the kings
of winter came to an end with the coming
of Aon the
Conqueror after aegon and his dragons
destroyed the combined armies of the
reach and the Rock at the Field of Fire
King torren Stark bent the knee and
swore fty to the tarian Dynasty in order
to spare the destruction of Winterfell
and his people he was Forever After
known as the king who knelt as a reward
for his submission aegon named Torin
Lord of Winterfell and Warden of the
north the north is the oldest and
largest of the Seven Kingdoms but house
Stark has not always held it when bran
the Builder raised Winterfell and
founded our line we were vassals to the
Barrow Kings who claimed descent from
the first king and thus dominion over
all the first men for free you can now
listen to the entire audio book Fire and
Blood On which house of the Dragon is
based and which covers the entire
targaryan history including current and
future events of House of the Dragon for
free with a notable trial using our Link
in the
description but after the long night it
was our house who built the wall and set
the knight's watch to guard the Realms
of men whilst our King sat in his Barrow
my ancestors eventually revolted waging
what singers call the Thousand Years War
to free our lands other families joined
us recognizing that the north is a cold
and hard land and needed a king who
served its people before
himself finally the last bar King bent
the knee and house darkk became the
kings of
winter yet we were Kings in name only
for by then the North had fractured into
Petty kingdoms and my ancestors would
struggle to unite it again for thousands
of years rodri Stark wrestled an
ironborn Lord for Bear Island and
granted it to house Mormont when he won
a younger son of our family Carl OnStar
won his own keep after he put down a
rebellion and founded house castar one
of the most powerful in the north when
the mandes were exiled from the reach my
ancestors shielded them and gave them a
home at the mouth of the white knife in
return for holding the river against
Pirates and Invaders now they're one of
the wealthiest houses in the
north I'm not so naive to pretend that
the entire North welcom Stark rule the
last W King was slain at Sea Dragon
point along with all his sons and beasts
the last Marsh King died at the hands of
King Rickard Stark and house Reed has
held the swamps of the neck ever since
houses Greenwood Towers Amber Frost none
survive today as more than names in
Dusty old books
but my ancestors never wanted to destroy
their fo's root and stem the umbers of
last Hearth and the Glovers of deepwood
M bent the knee and became loyal vassals
of house dark the Red Kings of House
Bolton wore cloaks made from the skins
of Stark princes they flayed and one of
the boltons was even known as the red
arm because he liked to plunge an arm
into the bellies of captive Starks and
pull out their entrails with his bare
hand the North deserved to be wiped
clean of
them yet my ancestors spared them after
their defeat because they believed the
north couldn't afford to fight itself
any
longer time soon proved them right when
the Andel swept into West Ros they
obliterated all the kingdoms of the
first men except the north each of the
Southern kingdoms fought the Invaders on
its own but the north fought as one when
the andal tried to sail up the white
knife the mandes fell on their ships
when the andal tried to March an army
through the neck the reeds fell on their
soldiers King Theon Stark even sailed
his own Army to the andle Homeland for
vengeance and slew hundreds of andle
Warriors when he returned he planted
their heads on spikes along our coasts a
warning to other wbe conquerors the
warning was heeded for thousands of
years until Aon the Conqueror the South
had already fallen to aegon and his
dragons only the north remained my
ancestor King torren Stark marched the
north down to the Trident and beheld
aon's army larger than torren own by
half and with three dragons circling
overhead many Northern banan wanted to
attack anyway claiming Northern Valor
would carry the day others wanted to
fall back to Mo Kalin and make a stand
there but torren had heard how the
armies of The Rock and the reach had
burned on the field of fire and had seen
the fires still glowing beneath the
rubble of Haren hor he knelt and laid
his ancient Crown at aon's feet and Rose
a king no more but Lord of Winterfell
and Warden of the
north some Northerners still sneer at my
ancestor as the king who knelt
forgetting that because of torren
they're alive today to sneer their
ancestors didn't leave their burned
bones at the Trident and their Twisted
swords didn't fill aon's new
thr Brandon the Builder founder of house
stock raised Winterfell with Giants over
8,000 years ago also nursemaids tell all
the children of the north the children
nod wide eyed unaware of the lesson
forced on them that if even Giants obey
a stark so too should they but like
every other Castle Winterfell was built
in pieces over thousands of years the
first men settled there because of the
hot springs that bubble through the
ground the water in the heat helped them
survive the northern Winters and they
built defenses to keep it for themselves
nobody raised the castle all at once
probably nobody meant to raise a castle
at all in those days the Starks were not
the greatest house in the north and
Winterfell was not the greatest Castle
bariton was the oldest dating to the
first king and the Starks fought the
Barrow Kings for a thousand years
greywater watch was like the chronog men
themselves the strangest only marriage
subdued its Marsh Kings but the greatest
rival to Winterfell was always the dread
for and my ancestors the Red Kings of
House Bolton if Tales can be believed we
fought from the long night until the
Andals came because of us Winterfell
raised its first walls when we took and
burnt the castle anyway Winterfell built
more keeps more walls more guard towers
they expanded the granaries and larders
to survive our sieges they tendered the
godswood to Wi in favor with the old
gods against us as the castle grew more
farmers and villagers flocked every
winter from across the north to huddle
under its walls raising the winter town
in the spring these villagers would find
themselves Marching In the Stark armies
to fight against us the greatness of
Winterfell is as much our doing as the
Starks but in the end neither its stone
walls nor its tall keeps and iron gates
could save Winterfell at its height it
could have lasted a year under heav Bes
Siege but a handful of ironborn seized
it in the night while its Lord the king
in the north was playing in the South my
dagger ended his reign as a boy looking
out from my father's Castle I thought
the sun could never set on the North so
vast did it seem part of me still does
the north is by far the largest of the
Seven Kingdoms and can fit the other six
inside it not that the others care C and
damp
that's how the southerners see the
north but without the cold a man can't
appreciate the fire in his Hearth
without the rain a man can't appreciate
the roof over his head let the South
have its sun flowers and
affectations we Northerners have home
mine was once Winterfell the ancient
seat of
my father's family how Stark who have
ruled the north since the first men and
were once the kings of
winter growing up lady Catlin made sure
I knew I wasn't a Stark No matter how
much blood I Shar with her trueborn
children but where their name rules over
the north mine is the
north snow our land stretches from the
wall down to the neck a narrow land that
devises from the rest of
Westeros Legend has it that the children
of the forest flooded in their war
against the first men that that's true
every Northman owes them a debt of
gratitude the swamps of the neck are as
good as the wall for keeping out
unwelcome armies and if the swamps don't
deter you the cronig men should small
shy people who rarely leave those swamps
and who follow house Reed The
Gatekeepers of the north and among the
most important and loyal Bannerman of
house
Stark also a bit strange I heard their
author fael he once as a child it's like
no other Lords ancient and dark they
swear by Earth and Water by bronze and
iron and by Ice and
Fire where house Reed holds the gate to
the north house Mandy holds the port
white Harbor the closest thing to a
southern city we have governed by the
closest thing to a southern family we
have Generations ago the mandes were
driven from the reach but the Stars gave
them their land in return for faaly
now white Harbor is the richest city of
the North and the Mand the richest
family not in gold and silver like their
southern counterparts but in fish grain
and trade as for the other Great
Northern houses the Starks brought them
into the fold during the Age of
Heroes Stark wrestled an ironborn for
Bear Island and gave it to the
Mormons Stark granted a keep and land to
a younger son Carlon in return for
putting down a rebellion his family then
grew up in to the car Starks Starks
fought the wildlings and their kings
Beyond the Wall beside the umbers of
last Earth thus earning their filty
Bolton but then they were the bane of
the north a few were even rumored to
where their enemies FL skins as Clarks
but after centuries of War they too bent
the
knee and so how Stark became the kings
in the north but never forgot that they
weren't the north when aegon and his
dragons landed on Westeros the kings of
The Rock and the reach sent all their
men to die to defend their
crowns torren star knelt to spare his
people the same fate he placed Duty
above
Pride